the world breaking clash between sukuna
and Gojo just shocked everyone and the
twist in the end was absolutely insane
so definitely stick around until the end
of this video the battle is finally
reaching its climax No One Is Safe and
the entire world is on the line so let's
get into it you guys know how this works
if you enjoy our jjk content and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now to help
me out with that the YouTube algorithm
and if you want to help us become a
special grade anime channel by hitting 2
million subscribers on YouTube Do me a
quick favor and subscribe right now
every subscription counts finally this
video will contain Jujutsu Kaizen manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned now in the previous
chapter the 2-1-1 Battle of sukuna and
maharaga vs Gojo turned into a
three-on-one battle as sukuna summoned
yet another shikigami on top of mahoraga
ashikigami known as merged Beast agito
agito is a giant Shiki gummy who appears
to be a fusion of two other shikigami
nue and divine dog totality although as
it turns out that's not quite accurate
stick around for the full truth later on
in the video Gojo then gets 3v1ed by
sukuna and the two giant shikigami but
Gojo is still holding his own he even
takes the time to mock sukuna saying
that he looks like a child who is being
protected by his two parents the this
translation translates this as Gojo
saying that sukuna looks like a lost
alien but I prefer the parents analogy I
think it makes a lot more sense under
the circumstances this kind of insult
definitely stings sukuna because Gojo is
making it clear that sukuna doesn't have
the ability to beat him on his own
sukura needs the help of these shikigami
he needs the help of megumi's Technique
we have to remember that this is a clash
of two Titans two of the strongest jiu
Jutsu sorcers in history and you better
believe that both of them want to secure
the title of the ACT actual strongest of
all time so sukuna definitely isn't
happy about Gojo openly questioning his
Integrity as a fighter at the end of the
previous chapter Gojo decided that he
had no other choice but to destroy
mahuraga with one single attack
unlimited Hollow the latest chapter
starts off with the spectators who are
watching the fight Utah decides that he
must intervene in order to help Gojo
because three on one just isn't fair but
kashimo calls him back and tells him not
to interfere hakari agrees with kashimo
and he tells Yuta to chill out for now
Gojo told them that they had his
permission to intervene only if Gojo
himself is weakened so much that he
becomes weaker than them however Yuta
says that this might be their best
chance to help Gojo defeat sukuna sukuna
can't use his domain right now since
he's using the 10 Shadows technique and
if Utah can enter the battle now he can
use Rika to fight off the two shikigame
so that Gojo can at least have a fair
one-on-one with sukuna Maki believes
that if anyone is going to intervene it
should be her after all if Gojo really
loses then they're going to need Yuta
and Rika as insurance to try and fight
against sukuna but then again Utah
thinks that if they intervene now and
sukuna is defeated then there is no need
for insurance at all this could be their
one and only chance to decisively beat
sukuna and then it's all over Yuji
actually backs yuta's decision but
kusakabe tells the kids to get a grip
Maymay then explains that despite the
fact that Gojo and sukuna are fighting
each other in the same battle they
actually have different requirements for
winning Gojo just needs to beat sukuna
because if he can do that then the other
Jujutsu Sorcerers including Yuta will be
able to handle kanjaku and any other
shenanigans that he might be up to but
tsukuna knows that even if he wins
against Gojo he then immediately has to
fight Utah kashimo hakari and the other
without a break how could he adds that
because suguna knows this he must have a
trump card that he is saving for later
and if they go out now he might decide
to use it against them basically if they
provoke sukuna into using his trump card
now but sukuna is not sufficiently
weakened by Gojo things could get bad
really quickly kusakabe believes that
even though things look bad now the
current setup has the highest
probability of success as things stand
now sukuna can't give it his all because
he has to worry about Gojo's backup
potentially showing up at any time and
Gojo is able to go all out without
worrying about others if Utah and the
others joined the fight then Gojo will
be worrying about them and trying to
make sure that sukura doesn't kill them
after all some of them are his students
and he feels responsible for them that
could actually make it harder for Gojo
to win for his part kashimo is a bit
less strategic in his thinking he sees
this as a matter of honor this is satoru
Gojo's fight and interfering with it
would be lame back on the battlefield
Gojo is still putting up a valiant fight
against the two giant shikigami he is
dodging and ducking and punching and
doing everything he can to make up for
the fact that he is clearly outnumbered
he even manages to land a black flash
punch on agito but the shikigami heals
almost instantly as it turns out agito
is not only a fusion of nue which
inherited Great Serpent and totality
Gojo believes that agito also has the
properties of mourn tiger and round deer
and of course we know that round deer
has the ability to heal using reverse
curse technique this makes agito
dangerous since sukuna can use him to
heal himself not to mention more and
tiger whom we still haven't met but who
likely also has some overpowered
abilities Gojo realizes that just like
with mahuraga he will have to destroy
agito in one shot and so he prepares to
do exactly that although preparing his
next move isn't exactly easy with both
shikigami attacking him relentlessly
over and over again they are attacking
so much because suguna is trying to
prevent Gojo from using purple and so
he's trying to keep Gojo busy at all
times at the start of the fight Gojo had
used purple at over 100 output and
sukuna was able to survive it because he
was four kilometers away and also he was
fresh and rested right now sukuna is not
at full strength the battle is taking
its toll even on him and he is also much
closer to Gojo so sukura knows that even
purple at just 100 would be fatal for
him at this point in time sukuna wants
the shikigami to show him what they're
truly made of after all they no longer
serve megumi they now serve the king of
curses sukuna himself in the very next
moment mahoraga's wheel turns again and
suddenly Gojo's right arm is severed at
the elbow by an invisible slash as the
stunned Gojo tries to come to terms with
the situation sukuna looks please The
Spectators are shocked that mahuraga
seems to now be able to somehow use
sukunas slashes and shoko is extremely
worried about Gojo it was already
established in the previous chapters
that Gojo is reaching his limit after
all those domain expansions and all that
reverse curse technique usage and after
all the injuries that he has sustained
during this fight shoko made it clear
that Gojo's healing speed is getting
noticeably slower and such a serious
injury will not be easy for Gojo to heal
in his current state the two shikigami
pounce on Gojo trying to take advantage
of the fact that he is now missing an
arm and then even sukuna gets in on the
action he launches a frontal assaulted
Gojo along with maharaga and he then
kicks Gojo right into the Monstrous arms
of agito but just when it looks like
agito is about to rip Gojo apart Gojo
uses blue at maximum output to
absolutely annihilate agito the narrator
proclaims that 41 seconds from now Gojo
will use hollow technique purple to
leave a scar on Shinjuku itself as this
epic battle finally enters its Climax
and that is how this insane chapter ends
the final panel of the chapter also
appears to show Gojo beginning to heal
his right arm so our boy is not done yet
and man this is crazy even though it
wasn't shown in the chapter the narrator
just told us that Gojo will successfully
use purple very soon so does that mean
that the battle is about to end I mean
tsukuna literally said that if Gojo uses
purple on him he will die so are we
supposed to believe that sukuna only has
41 seconds left to live let's be honest
the way that Shonen manga sometimes
works those 41 seconds could be
stretched out for like three chapters
but still I just don't think that sukuna
is really about to die so soon maybe the
attack is going to get rid of maharaga
but it's still too early for sukuna to
fall although this does raise the
question what is next for sukuna if Gojo
continues to destroy the shikigami like
he just did agito what will sukuna's
next strategy be in this chapter sukuna
revealed that he is in real danger of
dying here at the hands of Gojo one
wrong move and he could be killed so
what's he going to do now what is
sukuna's trump card that everyone has
been talking about definitely let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments below what is the trump card
also let's talk a bit about the
possibility for interference in this
fight in this chapter we saw that Utah
nearly intervened but he was stopped by
the others at what point do you think
that they might actually intervene or
could this idea that Gojo's allies are
going to terrain actually be
misdirection by Gage maybe while we're
talking about Utah and kashimo and the
others in the reading in the fight
kenjaku actually ends up pulling some
trick on Gojo so while we're all waiting
for Gojo's allies to jump in kenjaku
jumps in instead I mean come on kanjaku
is definitely planning something big
he's not just going to sit on the
sidelines for the rest of the story we
can't let this epic battle between
sukunai and Gojo distract us from the
big picture and throughout the Jujutsu
Kaizen story kanjaku has been the one
shaping the big picture from the Shadows
all in all this was another incredible
action-packed chapter full of tension
and intensity and I can't wait to see
what happens next if you're looking for
more epic jjk content to watch next
check out our new video that explains
and ranks every special grade sorcerer
Andrew jutsuka then link on screen and
in the description if you enjoy rjjk
content and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you want to help us become a special
grade anime channel by hitting 2 million
subscribers subscribe right now